♪
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS ARE READY
TO SHIP GRANDPA JOE OFF TO THE
NURSING HOME FOR GOOD.
MORE FOLLOW FROM A
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT THAT
INDICATES MANY IN THE PARTY ARE
READY TO DUMP JOE BIDEN IN 2024
BECAUSE OF HIS ADVANCED AGE AND
CALAMITIES UNDER HIS WATCH, BUT
THE PRESS SECRETARY LAUGHING OUT
QUESTIONS ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
FITNESS FOR OFFICE.
A SPEAKER DOES THE
PRESIDENT HAVE THE STAMINA
PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY TO
CONTINUE ON EVEN AFTER 20204?
>> YOU ARE ASKING ME THIS
QUESTION?
OH, MY GOSH, AND HE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES!
I CAN'T KEEP UP WITH HIM.
WE GOT BACK FROM MEXICO AND FROM
CALIFORNIA, THAT IS NOT A
QUESTION THAT WE SHOULD EVEN BE
ASKING.
JUST LOOK AT THE WORK THAT HE
DOES.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, JESSE, SHE
CAN'T KEEP UP WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: JESSE JR. COULD KEEP
UP WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS NOT EVEN SMILING COMING
TO SEE THIS?
AND GOT THE MEMO, PROBABLY A
POLLING MEMO OR SOME
POWER BROKERS AT THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE SAID THAT HE
WAS GOOD FOR GETTING TRUMP OUT
OF THERE, BUT IS NOT PERFORMING.
HAS PERFORMANCE ISSUES, YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT, GREG.
SO CNN IS NOW AND ON THE GET RID
OF JOE THINGS SOME THE TIMES IS
IN IN ON IT.
IT'S OUT.
SO HE IS BAD FOR RATINGS AT CNN.
HE IS BAD FOR BUSINESS, LOOK AT
THE STOCK MARKET.
YOU THINK THAT DONORS WANT TO
SUFFER A RECESSION THIS SUMMER?
WE ARE WIPING OUT EVERYTHING WE
HAVE GAINED UNDER HIS PRESIDENCY
SO FAR AND THEY HAVE HAD IT.
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT THEM OUT
TO PASTURE RIGHT AFTER THE
SHREDDING AND THE MIDTERMS AND
THE QUESTION IS HOW LONG IS IT
GOING TO TAKE JOE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING?
BECAUSE THE MAN HAS PRIDE, HE IS
A BIDEN, HE HAS WANTED TO BE
PRESENT IN HIS ENTIRE LIFE AND
HAS RUN THREE TIMES, SO MAYBE
SUSAN RICE GETS IN THERE, THE
OBAMA'S ARE CIRCLING, SOMEBODY
HAS TO TELL JOE, AXELROD IS
SENDING SMOKE SIGNALS, HE HAS TO
GO BECAUSE THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024 NEED TIME TO FUND RAISE,
CONTACT DONORS, AND
LICKETY-SPLIT AFTER THE
MIDTERMS.
AS DANA PREDICTED.
A LONG TIME AGO.
>> Dana: THE MONDAY AFTER
THANKSGIVING.
>> Greg: JUDGE, WHY DON'T THEY
GIVE HIM A GOLD WATCH?
>> Judge Jeanine: BECAUSE HIS
SON IS TRAVELING AROUND, HERE'S
THE PROBLEM.
IF YOU LISTEN TO
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE, THE PROBLEM
IS SHE SAYS OH, MY GOD, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
OF COURSE HE IS UP TO IT.
WHAT DOES ONE HAVE TO DO WITH
THE OTHER?
AND THEN SHE SAYS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO WITH
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO.
WHO DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF?
KAMALA HARRIS.
IT'S LIKE THEY ARE TALKING IN
VERBAL CIRCLES.
BUT IN THE END, THIS IS ABOUT
JOE BIDEN NOT WANTING TO GIVE UP
THE SPOTLIGHT.
HE IS STILL CONVINCED AND SO
EGOTISTICAL THAT HE DOES NOT
WANT TO GIVE IT UP.
MAYBE IT MIGHT JUST BE ABOUT
PEOPLE SAYING JOE, WE WANT YOU
TO STAY THERE, BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO GIVE IT TO
KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT KAMALA IS SO HORRIBLE,
STAND THERE.
WE WILL DO WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS CAN BE SEEN AS
PUSHING KAMALA HARRIS OUT OF THE
WAY OFF THE BACK, SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIG PIECE OF IT.
BUT I REALLY THINK THAT
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE'S ANSWER WAS
RIDICULOUS.
I CAN'T KEEP UP WITH HIM, HE IS
GOING TO DO WHAT HE IS GOING TO
DO.
THAT'S NOT A QUESTION YOU SHOULD
ASK, ARE YOU KIDDING?
HE STUMBLES UP AIR FORCE ONE
EVERY TIME HE WALKS UP.
HE IS EMBARRASSING.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO SAY, DANA,
I SAID THIS LAST WEEK AND FIND
MYSELF REPEATING MYSELF AGAIN
WHICH IS A SURPRISE.
WE ARE GIVING HIM KIND OF -- WE
ARE GIVING HIM A GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE PASS ON THE STUFF THAT HE
ACTUALLY DOES BY JUST TALKING
ABOUT HIS COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT THE BUCK
STOPS THERE, THESE ARE HIS
DECISIONS AND POLICIES AND OWNS
THEM, SO THE MEDIA DOES
SOMETHING YOU WILL SEE FOREVER
THEY BROKE THE SEAL.
NOW YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IT
EVERYWHERE, BECAUSE NOW THERE IS
NO PUTTING THIS HORSE BACK IN
THE BARN.
HOW MANY METAPHORS CAN I USE IN
THIS?
>> Greg: YOU ARE UP TO TWO.
>> Dana: YOU WILL SEE THE
DEMOCRATS DISTANCING THEMSELVES
FROM JOE BIDEN ARE RUNNING
AGAINST THEIR OWN PARTY, BUT
LOOK BENEATH THE SURFACE FOR
EXAMPLE THE SENATOR IN NEVADA
WHO IS ON THE RUN, HER NAME IS
CATHERINE CORTEZ MASCO, SHE IS
BASICALLY SAYING, NO, I'M
DISTANCING MYSELF FROM HIM.
BUT BOTH JOE BIDEN 98% OF THE
TIME AND YOU SEE A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS TRY TO DO THIS BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN, ALSO TOMORROW
MORNING AT 9:00 A.M. IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, ALL OF THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO HAVE A MESSAGING
MEETING ON THE ECONOMY.
IT IS NOT DEMEANING THEY NEED TO
HAVE, IT'S ON THE ECONOMY AND
POLICY NOT JUST ON MESSAGING.
>> Greg: LAST WORD, GERALDO,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Geraldo: TO THE JUDGE'S
POINT, "THE NEW YORK POST" SO
CLEVERLY SAID TODAY DEMOCRATS
CAN BE CONSIDERED FOR ONLY
CONSIDERING KAMALA HARRIS
STANDING BETWEEN THEM AND
DONALD TRUMP IN SAYING THAT 80
IS A NEW 75.
[LAUGHTER]
NO, I THINK HIS PROBLEM IS THAT
HE IS AN OLD 79.
HE IS ONLY EIGHT MONTHS OLDER
THAN I AM, AND HE LACKS A
CERTAIN VIGOR AND ENERGY AND I
THINK THAT IT IS TRAGIC.
YOU CAN ARGUE WHOSE FAULT IT IS,
OF COURSE.
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE I HAVE READ
IN THE STOCK MARKET VERY ROCKY,
I THINK THAT I WOULD BE WORKING
TILL I'M A HUNDRED AT THIS RATE.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE CRASH
HAPPENED IN 2008 I WAS LIVING IN
EDGEWATER ON THE HUDSON RIVER
AND HAD A DOCK THERE WITH A POOL
ON IT AND I WAS SWIMMING IN THE,
THE MOON WAS OUT AND I STARTED
YELLING, I'M NOT SELLING, I'M
NOT SELLING, ANYWAY --
>> Jesse: YOU HAD TO THROW IN
THAT YOU ARE.
>> Geraldo: I DID NOT DROWN.
>> Gre